[Música]
o nome já diz o nome é que ele vai
começar já pela parte da empresa eu vou
falar com um problema que eu tenho eu
sou digital atendente de creche cuco
digital tem maneira de conseguir uma
vaga
começaram a me ver como era pequeno eu
cresci ouvindo gente já estava
confirmado quando quando a 56s e chega
ao mundo não é o que pensa o tempo tá
estamos aqui na internet internet foi
nessa altura começou a entrar em
portugal mas não era certa gente eu
passei mais anos pensar o que é que eu
ia fazer um álbum digital é claro
encontrou nas consolas
ok isto é hora de gastar
encontrei nas consolas passar muito
tempo olhando do alto verão sox
imaginava como é que seria estarão
valendo como era que o mundo virtual
quem é que eu fazia
quem é que eu desenhava não transferiu
para programar mas quem é construir suas
agendas tempo e algumas coberturas crato
pintada em branco na altura é normal
afinal fácil manter seis tinham como o
computador e já 98 para eu subo foi
aquele momento enquanto eu beijo técnico
entrar em casa como o módulo baixo do
braço eo alto ganhei alguém grande
eu sabia que lembra que a lei de uma
semana duas antes eo quanto é que o
técnico foi quando é que o técnico não
chega o homem chegou e começa a chorar
rota o módulo começam daqui uns barulhos
típicos de modo que a gente tem é sobre
isso que está a falhar e não quem está
numa final da liga dos campeões depois
de ter sido criado pela internet porque
104 homens saiu acabou essa queda já que
minha vamos sentar em nono lugar está
sendo usada no lugar
tentava ver o fim da internet que é
impossível mas tentava dos sites que
está procurando opções estavam
escondidos na viciado em conteúdo
até que também falta do chefe do milho
que quer ser e foi já que os andares em
construção sentava nickname ruim na
história rafael espectáculo das o
assunto então muita gente
três meninas e um menino menor as
pessoas e nós além das que mais nos
radares nos amigos e não é somente uma
vida muito dance espero que continue
assim sempre muito tempo uma experiência
que jamais da série ou mais a economia
josé amim planta foi em 2003 criou um
site quando coloquei fotos normais
quanto as minhas forças com amigos fotos
com amigos coisa banal
o que é certo é que nesta altura não
estamos a viver agora nessa trama fala a
língua pátria não posso impor licenças
não ter faltas - entretanto a falta da
mãe que estamos num jantar para o
próximo verão falar comigo
muitos moram aqui mal professores vieram
falar comigo button fizesse sair ali eu
estou aqui há cinco anos da nato neste
de self fotos a comida e não sabia isso
não é mascada imaginava
mostrando não ter aquela que sai curta
noé psb-rs que sites usados têm
publicado permite que a pessoa não
percebe isto está internet
já em 2006 que passa a cuidar das minhas
coisas que fizemos quando os meus
colegas estão a falar foi criado um
fórum estão à espera que uma cena mais
séria e vamos ter que o custo na lata
que custou caro contém - pode ser que o
curso estarão e mães a falar da matéria
a gente tem esse olhar todas as outras
tarefas além das aulas que os outros mas
foi do santa mãe deu pra ver aquela
experiência como é que se moviam dentro
do fórum
a cama sempre gostou dela sempre
aprender alguma coisa
tem também outra história engraçada
ainda na faculdade a uma altura temos lá
em cima e nós temos que tomar banho e
não havia água quente
vamos jogar se passava com a melhoria
nos ver quanto é que vai ser uma final o
técnico o técnico nunca são 50 euros já
cobra mais 50 100 mil euros
ao todo são paulo comprando é mano
a mãe está 100 euros lugares como na
caldeira
quero fazer uma trilha seu nome no
google plus guga começa já esta causa
não temos um modelo normal não temos um
local da ilha
não temos de ver como estava o que é
certo domínio espanhol que acho que eu
vivia não serem maioria qualquer coisa
que tem um plano que nós escreveu má
forma simples nós temos aquela quer casa
tem de enfrentar a caldeira
vimos um carro que era é só carregar no
botão foi a senhora faz festa não quis
conhecer o que é nosso amigo a gente
entra outra história outra forma digital
basta digitar o termo área também ela me
ajudou foi a matemática por exemplo você
pensar numa chapa de osmar que nada que
eu tinha antes que nós possamos agora
também não me achar
a matéria pode ser interessante mas a
forma como é nada isso não era muito a
minha banda tinha que fazer senão aquela
do curso não é
então falei comigo estou nele o homem
gritou o youtube
procurei a matéria estava lá e
matemática para o deputado que continua
disponível no momento três pessoas
diferentes nos três meses vários
programas em cada janela militar cunha
até às seis da manhã que não se
importava podia manter o xará entradas
falar outras línguas não se importando
em podia estar amanhã pa
nunca mais outra vez no nosso termômetro
saio tem este método só assim aprenda
digital hoje em dia ministro uma janela
também da aprendizagem e nesse caso
filmado em vigor já que foi mais fácil
aquilo não gastem é explicada por mais
fazem contagem de vista foi tranquilo
mas na frente
já em 2011 criamos por sites mais
empresarial
aprendi mais uma vez que o youtube eo
google com as amigas do costume
o site é mais por que está sendo contado
certo mais institucional é um site para
colocar a empresa no mapa das 500
empresas agora apresenta seu rock
a empresa mãe da pequena empresa hum
vickers a confecção do vestuário a agora
história senhoras em tamanhos grandes
em dois tamanhos lá desde o 34 e aos 64
anos aprofundou neste tempo isso não
rompa eu sou isso não sabe se não se diz
aqui um grande saque no décimo game mas
tem que fazer é fazer com que todos os
sites abaixo dele mesmo
nenhuma foi então que em 2012 a criança
saiba que a empresa é esse site claro já
foi feito com mais minuciosamente já foi
o site mais trabalhado também já tenham
já tinha aprendido alguma coisa antes o
site já com quem é claro como é normal
ficar viciado um canal estatísticas tipo
matem os ilícitos nas vendas para quem
está comprando menos gente que fala que
passar a ter que aprender em algum link
ao incidente na opção assim só uma turma
achado com as pessoas mas nunca falei
isso ninguém sabe responder
até que teve um trauma pós graduação em
marketing digital em 2013
na altura da adolescência quando os
amigos que as festas sala paulo vi essa
mixaria achou da vontade que elas também
tenham essas cenas foram impecáveis não
tem os meus colegas com músicas foi
impecável em cima da gente do mundo
digital filho amigo também virtualmente
muita gente que não vai falar em
julgamentos que a população continua em
qualquer um dos times não dá preciso uma
informação mais informação não é isso
que eu quero quero tornar a empresa quer
tomar o site tão grande como como como
os maiores continuam entre as
informações neste caso são presenciais
com o são paulo entendeu não ser aquelas
informações online informações
já dei aulas ano ano cria uma queda de
comércio digital e também já assumiu a
dar aulas na faculdade e uma coisa só
nelas que mesmo assim postar falar olha
só estão obrigados a seguir mostra estão
agora obrigados a sentar se ouvirmos o
que será que o chato na rua e já tem as
pessoas das aulas já recebe uma
motivação para dar aulas
e pronto eu sou eu aqui com umas calças
tamanho 64 enganado é e é isso que vou
ficar agora no caso
no nicho de mercado de trabalho porque o
mundo está nas grandes e nas roupas para
gordinhas que eu posso dizer é que esta
é marca é um técnico da empresa o site
preocupa sim eu quero também dar a quem
vai com o site não é só um site que mexe
em toda a empresa mas todo digital
méxico uma empresa é um exemplo muito
base que mostraram muito bem no nosso
nosso contar que se não fosse de
contatos é nosso negócio mais
preocupações é e não são executadas nos
filho vai crescer a nossa roupa só uma
coisa já vista em o centeio natureza
tenha certeza eu também tenho nada com
isso que há tantas crianças ea própria
roupa começa a transformar a quando os
comentários que recebemos dos figurantes
que temos ao nível digital e também na
nossa loja é parte da fotografia à parte
da cbf é super importante enquanto uma
novela no modelo maga palestra um é que
sejam 10 e messi assim necessário a
roupa que é sempre bem vinda mas no
início não acontece é preciso ter
cuidado mas vou tentar muito bem feita
não pode haver aquelas vindas quando
damos a fotografar é temos que ter
atenção em todos os tempos temos que
trabalhar muito porque também é
fotografia que vai na internet
outra parte um show com a empresa foi a
partida lance tão stock options que
deputados estão stoxx a realidade do
mundo virtual para conseguirmos explicar
cada vez mais rápido para em seguida
serem cada vez mais rápido e claro com
as condições e os fãs estão mais
importante à parte eu quero focar mais
na parte de comunicação
eu costumo dizer nunca ninguém comprou
uma empresa de internet no máximo compra
uma imagem que viram um vídeo que até
mesmo as centenas 12 títulos que aterrou
em estou mostrando as sensações que
comprar essa planilha só compro quando
chegou em casa e aqui uma grande lacuna
aqui um enorme buraco ano digital em
relação ao mundo real não é o teu amor
humano não aquela opção auxiliarmos
naquela pessoa que nos distancia ficava
em 8 levando terror não temos alguém
acompanhando lado e nós para tentar
tapar esse buraco
posso dizer que tentámos ser uma uma luz
branca é é um conceito nós queremos ver
que o nosso cliente sim domingo nós que
nós queremos que nossos clientes nem
aproximação com os mais ligados nós
queremos que o que e aos meus filhos
andam nas horas que hoje em dia a gente
sabe como é que são a renunciar é uma
coisa normal alguém insultar nos nossos
clientes nosso caso nós temos sentimos
isso que um lado defender-nos porque
realmente nosso nós e gosta do nosso
time se você perguntar mas como é que tu
manos e assuma uma nova grande não dá
muito bem como de resto os comentários
que recebi em troca disso se tratando em
época também treinar um dia e claro tem
alguns exemplos
tenho um exemplo muito engraçado é o
vento levou e também na parte de
atendimento
tomei um caso fácil no quarto set foi um
pouco lento legal tão ruim assim ele
poderia minar que a inflação precisa da
ajuda atende à vontade aqui pra ajudar
eu estou aqui pra isso
então minha mãe não gostava do farol
eu nem que se não vai vai foi aluno eu
estou faro num brutal dal pizzol mas
alguma coisa não não isto cria estão
prontos e não precisam nem comigo eu
peguei ela desligam eu fiquei a pensar
que quem é que vai na rua empresa que no
nosso fórum olhar para a empresa o que
só prova que nós resolvemos os problemas
começam lembrou de mim no momento tem
nenhum problema
outra situação que está ainda aquém de
uma cleantes é e essa pose pra contar a
história legal foi a primeira vez que
dois assim está em falta em wilson você
precisa que nós não estamos ainda nos
preocupa porque eu estou isso é um
comportamento digno então eu que precisa
eu tô aqui com um problema e não sei que
também escolher é fácil mandar essas
medidas e eu sou uma bruxa má
mas eu tenho um metro e um metro um
metro começar bem mas em uma noite
marcante que estaria usando o nosso
corpo ela a primeira já não é somente
spams participação que leva ela tem vai
sobrar um metro no ano passado o caso
então o senhor assim é
estou aqui em cima de uma cadeira em
cima da pedra que cai em uma cadeira e
uma marina ao lado eo sim
o tac com uma corda e uma corda ela
assim o conserto e troca de escola
possui mil metros o que é certo é aquela
menina de roupa que ele é alencar
aumento ficou em segundo ficou o goiano
não tocamos também alegou esta
problemática dos tamanhos é uma
realidade sua cliente mas também
encomendar e se enganaram em um
centímetro a mais larga perto quando são
3 x 4 x 5 x 0 aos 6 visão das coisas não
são assim
tem mesmo que ficava isso não sou é
sempre trocar e foi aqui que eu arranjo
aí uma pequena solução é também é esse
que vos vai mostrar que há hoje é santa
catarina
ninguém morreu pode acabar
e vamos mostrar uma solução não é criar
e desenvolver
vou provar que este banco eu creio que
desligar seus pés e trocar só e somente
só que tem uma aplicação foi criada há
pouco tempo está em fase de testes mas
eu penso que isso vai dar
depois mostro o resultado do segmento
ok podem ligar as luzes o senhor
catarina já não é que é isso que eu
criei aqui é vacinar salvar minha loja
online como várias vozes principais fora
esse mundo fora você sinceramente estava
lá a 50 mas era realmente uma coisa que
levava 18
eu só queria que o número do tipo achar
que está em causa de uma semana ou não
sair não sai mais ninguém na mão
mas foi muito bom também aquela cena
padrão idéias los para já valeu a pena
de cair no caminho mudando aqui um pouco
é o discurso para terem estado a
aplicação vai ter nove anos enquanto é
eu criei então falar aqui de uma outra
coisa - tentamos aqui um pouco o
discurso tentar fazer aqui uma pequena
na finalização
imaginemos os mosteiros antigamente nos
três ligamentos mães deviam lá estão
peças de todas as mães vivem lá e mas
quando passavam os dias a estudar e
desenvolver o time do texas tem um livro
nos anos passados que os livros que os
próprios mesmo que os próprios criam e
passaram a desenvolver em áreas como
agricultura medicina mas que mentiram
aos nós somos senhores do conhecimento
hoje em dia um jovem uma criança o que
está aí consegue ter acesso a essa
informação e muita mais se esquecem do
quarto uma criança ou jovem consegue 13
quilos que tomará muito menos nós
conseguimos ganhar fazer a trabalhar já
no meu trabalho
saiba mais na edição de vídeos criado à
imagem e à mesma programado quem não
quis apresentar detalhes fazem em 45
quarto
mais tarde esses jovens vão arranjar
emprego
quem sabe o tempo longo demais que deus
não aprova essa queda vez mais coisas
diferentes
basicamente nós estamos lixados tem como
ter connosco e nós não temos a menor
hipótese se não ganharmos um combóio
claro que eu saí também para trabalhar
nos projetos - com pessoas do mundo
inteiro se conseguem fazer coisas
fantásticas e já me aconteceu para
trabalhar com pessoas na austrália
pessoas todo lado e pensar nisto
a mensagem que eu queria deixar aqui
hoje uma mensagem nada com ela
mas essas crianças e esses jovens têm
uma saída brutal uma ferramenta brutal
suas próximas reuniões do que o tempo
mostrará um jovem deste mostramos é que
eles tenham acesso mas já pensa parece
que acham super heróis aqui nós temos 11
coral da informação de que eles querem
intimidar aqueles que querem nos a nós
educar essas crianças e esses jovens e
nunca mas não quero fechar a porta
digital botar humberto se viciar em
visitar
[Aplausos]
[Música]